EXPLOSIVE GROWTH:
1 million users in 1 year.
This is what a new email client named Skiff
has managed to do.
Of course, this is nothing in comparison to
Gmail’s total user count of 1.8 billion
users.
But, this is also what makes Skiff so impressive.
In an era where Gmail is ubiquitous, Skiff
has managed to grow to a million users from
scratch within a matter of months.
On paper, Skiff doesn’t offer anything remarkable
per se.
They’re just an encrypted email client with
a solid UI.
What’s even more interesting is that Skiff
is able to get away with a much more traditional
avenue of monetization.
Nowadays, all the craze is to make everything
free and come up with super creative ways
to monetize users whether that be collecting
data or running ads.
I mean this was literally the selling factor
of Gmail: a free invite only email with extraordinary
storage capacity.
But, this comes with its own set of disadvantages.
For one, Google is an ad company who makes
money by getting to know you as well as possible.
And what better way to get to know you than
reading our emails.
This was actually a big controversy back in
the day and Google apparantly stopped reading
our emails back in 2017.
But, certain smart features suggest the opposite
so you can take that for what you will.
Skiff on the other hand can’t read your
emails even if they wanted to because everything
is end to end encrypted.
As such, they have turned to a more archaic
mode of monetization where people actually
pay the company directly for the service.
Maybe some of you are too young to know about
this but this is how companies used to do
business and Skiff is trying to bring this
model back to one of the most competitive
industries in the world.
While they do have a generous free tier with
10 gb of storage and even custom domain support,
the only way they make money is from people
who spring for the Essential or Pro tier.
Given their user count though, it doesn’t
seem like this is really slowing down their
adoption.
They even have some super notable users like
Vitalik Buterin.
But, it’s not all sunshines and rainbows.
To get this point, Skiff has had to raise
over $14 million.
Also, while Skiff does have quite a bit of
momentum right now, it’s not clear if they’ll
be able to maintain this momentum after they
burn through the privacy and UI centric folks.
The reality is that while the average person
would like to have more privacy, they’re
also too lazy to change anything they’re
currently doing.
So, join me as we take a look at whether Skiff
is truly the next big thing or if it’s just
a niche product that’ll never be more than
just that.
THE CASE FOR SKIFF:
The main appealing factors of Skiff are pretty
simple.
It’s probably the best looking mail client
on the market and it has privacy that even
experts seem to like.
In fact, all of Skiff’s code is open source,
so if you’re a coder, you can take a look
at exactly what the platform tracks, how it
encrypts your emails, and whether they’re
actually being honest.
Even if you're not a coder, you can rest assured
that everything truly is private as Russia
has given it the seal of approval by banning
it.
Skiff is also trying address traditional shortcoming
regarding mail filters and centralization
but really the selling factors are the UI
and privacy.
That’s pretty much it, but oftentimes that’s
all you need.
When you’re addressing something as established
as email, there’s really not much you can
change but that’s ok.
You don’t need to revolutionize email, you
just have to make email noticeably better.
I mean this has been Google’s secret sauce
the entire time.
They were never first to anything they did.
There were plenty of search engines before
Google, plenty of emails before Gmail, and
plenty of browsers before Chrome.
Fun fact, Google’s own CEO, Eric Schmidt,
was strongly opposed to building Chrome as
he felt that entering the browser wars was
futile.
In fact, he single handedly delayed the launch
of Chrome by 6 years but that didn’t stop
Chrome from being the biggest success the
browser space has ever seen.
The truth is that while first movers do indeed
have an advantage, that’s all it is: an
advantage.
It’s not endless monopoly over a certain
domain.
I mean, ChatGPT is disrupting Google as we
speak which brings us into the our next point
for Skiff which is the sentiment surrounding
Google.
One of the biggest reasons that Google was
so successful was because of their underdog
nature.
People loved to support the scrappy startup
that was Google.
Their motto of “Don’t be evil” resonated
with users.
Why support hotmail and internet explorer,
products from the evil tech monopoly, Microsoft,
when you could support Google.
But while this worked in Google’s favor
back in the 2000s, this is no longer the case.
Today, Google is very much the evil tech monopoly
that Microsoft was back in the day meaning
that Google is primed for disruption.
I mean just take a look at how quick people
were to laugh at Bard.
Sure, Bard made a mistake but if Google was
still a scrappy startup, I bet people would’ve
focused on the millions of items that Bard
did correctly as opposed to the few that Bard
didn’t.
But since Google is a giant the sentiment
is: oh Google is a trillion dollar monopoly
and can’t even get this right?
What a joke?
This shift in sentiment is subtle but it makes
all the difference.
All of a sudden, a service like Skiff that
actually respects your privacy is worth a
shot.
What’s the worst that could happen?
It sucks and you come back to Gmail?
Clearly not very high stakes.
Speaking of high stakes, Skiff doesn’t have
a very high barrier for entry.
One of the advantages of entering an established
market is that people are already familiar
with the product.
People already know why email is useful, how
to send an email, what cc and bcc mean.
So, Skiff doesn’t have to convince people
on adopting email, they just have to convince
people that Skiff is the best platform for
email.
And given that most people are relatively
tech savvy nowadays, getting them to give
it a shot isn’t too hard.
This is why we see so many apps blow up basically
overnight.
In fact, if you truly have a winning product,
it’s easier to go viral today than ever
before.
TikTok gained 100 million users within a matter
of 9 months.
More recently, ChatGPT was able to garner
100 million users within just 2 months.
20 years ago, such traction would’ve been
impossible regardless how good the product
was.
Nowadays, information is simply shared and
absorbed so quickly that if you have momentum
on your side, you can go extremely far.
So, trying to challenge even something as
big as Gmail is very much possible but there’s
of course some pretty big hurdles along the
way as well.
THE CASE AGAINST SKIFF:
Likely the biggest elephant in the room is
who cares?
Nowadays, we all see articles about Facebook
and Google and basically every other company
invading our privacy.
And while I do believe that everyone should
have the right to privacy, realistically speaking,
I think the vast majority of us have become
numb to the idea.
I mean, is having a truly private email really
going to change anything?
Are you also going to find alternatives for
Instagram and YouTube and Google Search and
TikTok and basically everything else as well?
I’m gonna guess probably not.
This isn’t to say that these companies are
in the right for collecting data on all of
us.
But I guess it’s simply a reality that most
of us have just come to accept as reality.
So, it’s not clear if the privacy argument
will really hit as well as you might think.
Speaking of privacy, it’s also not clear
how much people actually care about privacy
when it comes to email in general.
I don’t know about you but virtually all
of my email use is professional.
The last time I actually emailed a friend
was like 2011.
So, there’s not anything espeically personal
that I send through email that I would want
to protect to begin with.
Most people use email for work or school to
contact coworkers, managers, professors, and
so on.
Or they use it to sign up for newsletters
and create accounts but very rarely do people
use email for social communication.
So again, not sure how much people will care
about privacy here.
Something else to note is that people don’t
really choose what email client they use for
work or school unless its like the Apple mail
app.
They just use whatever the school or company
uses.
Skiff’s new feature that allows people to
use a custom domain for free does technically
make this possible but we’ll have to see
how many people actually care to take advantage
of this feature.
Also, there’s no way we can discuss the
future of Skiff without mentioning ProtonMail.
If you’re not familiar with ProtonMail it’s
basically just an older Skiff.
ProtonMail launched back in 2014 with the
promise of better privacy and a more refined
UI and they’re doing pretty good.
They have over 70 million accounts but this
brings up the question: what does Skiff really
offer over ProtonMail.
Well, we can’t really make an argument based
on UI because that’s subjective.
And to be honest, they both have a great modern
UI so it’s really just personal preference.
There’s also of course some minor differences
in terms of pricing and features but really
the main difference seems to be the encryption
standard.
ProtonMail uses something called PGP encryption
which has been the standard for decades.
Skiff argues that PGP encryption is outdated
and that there are far better encryption standards
out there and they could be absolutely right.
But how many people actually care about this?
As far as the average user is concerned, both
email clients are end to end encrypted.
Also, all email clients will claim that they
have the best encryption.
So unless you really understand these encryption
standards, it doesn’t really mean anything
to the average person.
And all of that brings us into likely Skiff’s
biggest shortall which is monetization.
Every dominant email that has ever existed
has come from a tech giant whether that be
Aol, Yahoo, Microsoft, or Google.
And the main reason for that is that email
simply works much better as a side business
than a main business.
You simply have to reach extraordinary scale
to start make any sort of profit.
ProtonMail for example is only possible because
of the generosity of its community.
And it seems that the only reason that Skiff
and their generous free tiers are possible
are because of insane VC money.
VC are willing to go quite far nowadays in
terms of funding but it’s not the same Google
launching Gmail in 2004 and subsidizing the
cost themselves.
As far as Google is concerned, even if Gmail
is a breakeven effort indefinitely or even
a slight loss, that’s a massive win as 1.8
billion users are even more integrated into
the Google ecosystem.
For Skiff, on the other hand, monetization
has to eventually work out and they have to
fundraise in the meantime.
Otherwise, their toast.
THE FUTURE OF SKIFF:
While launching a new email client in the
2020s may seem crazy, it’s actually way
more viable than you think.
The sentiment against Google paired with the
insane virality potential of modern apps makes
a new email client quite viable.
Combine this with some extra privacy and a
better UI and Skiff may very well have a winning
product on their hands but their success is
by no means guaranteed.
Several companies have picked up on this trend
of adding privacy and UI to replace offerings
from big tech companies.
Some other examples are Signal, BeReal, and
ProtonMail.
Some of theses anti big tech offerings end
up panning out while others end up dead in
the water.
Only time will tell if Skiff has enough mojo
to convince the general public to make the
switch.
Schools are already ditching Google in general
so that may be an opportunity for Google.
Check out this video to learn more about why
schools are ditching Google.